MALE SPEAKER:
Welcome, everybody.
We're here at the
Devoxx 2014 conference.
And I'm here with Brian.
Hi, Brian.
And we're here to talk about
cloud and the Google Cloud
Platform obviously.
And maybe we want to start with
Compute Engine, because that's
what maybe a lot of
people are familiar with,
at least the concept,
so tell us more
what Google Cloud
Compute Engine is?
Then we'll talk about
Docker and even Kubernetes.
Really exciting, I think.
BRIAN DORSEY: Awesome.
OK.
So Compute Engine is Google's
virtual machines as a service.
So it's basically
a virtual machine
running Linux or
Windows, then running
that on Google's infrastructure.
So you get very reliable
consistent performance.
You get very, very
good network access.
You know, we're running
in the same data centers
that Google runs
its own software in,
and so you can run your software
right next to our software
and have it live on the
internet very closely.
MALE SPEAKER: So
one thing I really
like about Compute
Engine, and many things
I think that people
would like about
Compute Engine, but the API.
Yeah, so what does the
API allow, and why would
people should even care?
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah, so
I'll take a step up.
So we have command line
tools, and web app tools,
and third-party
tools, and all of them
talk to Compute Engine,
the service, via this API.
And so it's a REST JSON API
that's available over HTTP.
We, of course, have
clients in about a dozen
different programming languages,
but it's straight REST.
So you can get it
off token and then
just talk to it
directly over HTTP.
MALE SPEAKER: So
Compute Engine is great.
It has all those great
features, but all you
have is a machine at
the end of the day.
It's just like really
low level stuff.
So at some point, you need
to build the infrastructure
on top of that.
So there is this
thing that everybody's
talking about including here
at Devoxx, which is Docker.
And the promise of Docker
is to be something that's
relevant to developers,
to production,
and solve a number of problems.
So what are we
doing with Docker?
And does that play even
well with Compute Engine?
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah absolutely.
Yes and yes, of course.
And Google is basically
all in on containers.
We've been doing
containers for a while.
We contributed some of the
early patches to a Linux kernel,
the [? C ?] group stuff.
We're continuing to work
with the Docker folks
on a libcontainer.
But containers are basically
this way of packaging up
your application and all of
its environment and OS level
resources.
So they'd always seize
the same environment
wherever you run it.
So you can run it
via your laptop.
You can run it in the cloud.
It's always the same.
And I think this is super
powerful, because like Compute
Engine is absolutely
a fantastic service,
but one way of looking
at it is that it's
basically re-implementing as
software APIs all the things we
used to do physically
in the data center.
So you go to the data center,
and you plug a machine in,
you hook drive up, you
connect it to the network,
you boot it up, you
turn it on, and we
have APIs for all of that.
And it's great, because
you can be automate it.
It's way more efficient.
But containers, this abstraction
they give you, the isolation
that they give you
is really allowing
us to build abstractions
that are higher
and let us think about
software on its own terms,
rather than how it fits into
a particular physical box.
MALE SPEAKER: So containers are
great, Docker in particular.
We would encourage
people to try it out.
They will have some
magical moment I think.
I hope.
But even though you're using
Docker, at the end of day,
you have like this
one container,
and it does great things, but
we have a great load balancer.
We probably want to scale.
That's kind of what we do
and what a lot of people
should do probably, offer
great services to their users.
So how do we solve the problem
of not reinventing the wheel
in terms of load balancing
a cluster of containers?
BRIAN DORSEY: Totally.
So yeah, we're super
excited about that.
In fact, to solve
that exact problem,
we've started an open source
project called Kubernetes.
So you can visit kubernetes.io
and find out all about it.
But in short, you
have this container,
and it creates this isolated
world for a given process
to run.
And I think it's easiest
to think about them
just as processes that always
have their own stuff with them,
right?
And so it works
very well to start
a bunch of those
up on one computer.
It's great.
You can be like, OK,
I'm all in on containers
like, I believe it.
This is going to work great.
I'll run containers across
500 of my machines right.
And I'll run 50 containers
on each machine.
And pretty soon,
you've got quite a lot
of containers running.
It becomes challenging
to figure out
how they should
talk to each other,
how to do version
upgrades between things,
how to like you say
load balance and keep
this whole system healthy.
And so Kubernetes is
directly an extraction
of Google's experience
like running
large container-based systems.
Some of the same
engineers who've
worked on multiple generations
of internal scheduling tools
at Google are working
on Kubernetes.
MALE SPEAKER: So
it's probably worth
mentioning that Kubernetes
is a greenfield project.
I mean they started from scratch
with a lot of experience that
went into this, but it is a
fully open source project.
The community that's
pretty much driving
at this point with a
lot of people on board
and using this in lots
of different context.
BRIAN DORSEY: And we're doing
the whole thing in the open.
We're working very,
very hard to make sure
that it runs everywhere.
Like you can actually run
Kubernetes on just your laptop
or you can run it
on machines you own.
You can run it on multiple
different cloud providers.
We've got partners like--
it's happening on GitHub,
and so many people
are participating.
We've got thousands of stars,
like hundreds of contributors.
And that's everything
from individual developers
kind of working on their own
time excited about this stuff
to some very large companies,
including Microsoft,
Red Hat, CoreOS, Docker
themselves-- a whole list
of folks that are
participating in this project.
MALE SPEAKER: And
obviously as Google, we
have a number of
things that maybe we
could do extra in terms of
not just providing the bits,
but maybe running this.
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah,
so then if you
run Kubernetes on
Google Cloud Platform,
it runs extremely well.
You get all the
benefits of our years
of building this infrastructure.
It taps in very
nicely like you say
to our load balancer
and other things.
And we just announced recently
an actual hosted version
of Kubernetes.
So if you don't want to go to
GitHub and like build the thing
and install it and
whatever, you can kind of
go to our web console,
create a cluster,
and just start using
it immediately.
MALE SPEAKER: And
everything's taken care of.
BRIAN DORSEY: All the cluster
and like management of itself.
MALE SPEAKER: The
networking, the container,
and keeping nodes alive, and--
BRIAN DORSEY: And actually,
that's a really key point.
One of the key differences
with Kubernetes,
as opposed to many
other approaches
to kind of managing a
cluster of containers,
is that it's declarative,
and it's actively
maintaining the state
of your environment.
So when you start a
container what you do
is you don't actually
say, start this container,
you say, I want this
container to be running.
And Kubernetes
watches the health,
make sure it stays running.
And if ever anything
happens to it,
it will replace it with
another copy of that container.
And that's true for
your entire system.
So if you create--
MALE SPEAKER: How
do you express that?
Is that declarative?
Is that an API?
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah, it's a
declarative JSON document.
So you create a tree
of configuration,
and you push that up to the API.
And then it will
keep the system--
it will set up the
system to look that way,
and then it'll keep
it looking that way
until you tell it otherwise.
And then when you want
to scale, you just
say, Oh, I want more of those.
And you resubmit the
document, and you get more.
MALE SPEAKER: So what is
the status of Kubernetes
as such and maybe the container
engine that you just mentioned,
which is the hosted version?
BRIAN DORSEY: And both of these
things are very, very new.
The entire container ecosystem
Docker and all the people
contributing to that, Kubernetes
itself, are all very new.
So this is moving
very, very quickly.
And to be honest, there's
a few rough edges still.
So if you play with
Kubernetes today,
you'll probably find
some challenges.
If you do find those
issues, please let us know.
On kubernetes.io, we
are active on IRC.
We're of course
active on GitHub,
email lists, and the like.
Let us know what works for
you, what doesn't work.
If you find things
you can't do, you
run into it some of these
rough edges, let us know,
and we'll make it better.
MALE SPEAKER: Awesome.
Thank you Brian.
Think containers-- cloud is
an awesome place to be in.
It's super exciting.
BRIAN DORSEY:
Containers everywhere.
MALE SPEAKER: Do try all of
that on the cloud platform,
on your laptop, anywhere.
Just build awesome apps.
Cheers.
BRIAN DORSEY: Go
build awesome stuff.
Thank you very much.